>> PREVIOUSLY ON AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> DIONNE AND RENEE
HAD A JOYFUL REUNION
WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
>> I SEE MY MOM AND MY BABY.
>> AND THE PHOTO SHOOT
WAS A TOP MODEL EXTRAVAGANZA.
>> AAH!
>> OH, I LOVE YOU!
>> NATASHA MADE FLAWED SKIN
FLAWLESS...
>> THERE YA GO!
>> BUT JAEL JUST FELL FLAT.
>> NOT SO SEXY, OKAY?
>> AND ONCE AGAIN,
THERE WAS NO SPARK
IN WHITNEY'S PHOTO,
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
SIX GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪♪♪
>> IT'S THE BOMB.
>> IT'S JUST--
IT'S GETTING HARDER,
AND I'M TRYING MY ASS OFF.
>> YOU'RE DOING REALLY GOOD.
>> BUT IT, LIKE, IT SUCKS
TO HEAR THAT I'M JUST GOING
DOWN AND DOWN.
>> YOU'RE JUST FALLING
AND FALLING.
WHERE'S THAT GIRL
THAT USED TO BE CALLED FIRST
EVERY WEEK?
>> I JUST FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE MAKING IT HARDER FOR ME,
BUT I'M STILL HERE. I'M STILL...
>> HEY.
>> FIGHTING FOR IT.
I NEED TO STEP UP MY GAME.
THE PRESSURE IS ON ALL THE TIME.
>> IT'S EXCITING
TO BE IN THE FINAL SIX.
I MADE IT MORE THAN
HALFWAY THROUGH.
I DID A GOOD JOB.
AND I NEED TO STAND OUT MORE,
I GUESS.
>> MOSCOW WAS, LIKE, ALL--
I HAD SO MANY FRIENDS,
AND WE WOULD GO OUT
ALL THE TIME, YOU KNOW?
AND I WAS IN, YOU KNOW,
I WAS --
>> ARE THERE A LOT OF
PRETTY GIRLS IN MOSCOW?
>> MM-HMM.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP IN RUSSIA,
I BELIEVED THAT
I CAN DO SOMETHING
BIGGER THAN JUST MARRYING
SOME GUY FROM THE--
FROM THE NEXT DOOR.
AND I FEEL SO STRONG.
I DON'T HAVE ANY COMPETITION.
AMERICANS ARE VERY PRETTY GIRLS,
BUT THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT.
>> EVERYBODY IN THE HOUSE
IS SO ECCENTRIC AND DIFFERENT.
THAT'S WHY I FEEL I DESERVE TO
BE HERE.
I HAVE COMPLETE FAITH IN MYSELF
BECAUSE I AM THE
SPREADER OF LIGHT.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> WE HEARD YA!
>> AH, HA HA!
♪♪♪
>> WAIT, I GOTTA GET READY
FOR TYRA.
OKAY.
(imitates Russian accent)
"TRUST ME, TALKING TO PEOPLE
EVERY DAY ISN'T AS EASY
AS IT LOOKS..."
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> LOVE, NATASHA.
(knock on door)
>> HI!
>> (laughs)
GIRLS, WE HAVE A VISITOR!
>> HI! HI, HI, HI.
>> OH, MY GOD,
THAT'S APRIL FROM CYCLE 2!
THAT GIRL IS
BEAUTIFUL IN PERSON.
>> SINCE THE SHOW,
I'VE BEEN WORKING AS A MODEL
IN THE UNITED STATES AND ABROAD.
ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING THINGS
THAT I'VE ACTUALLY GOTTEN TO DO
IS TO BE A CORRESPONDENT...
TAKE YOUR LUXURY TO THE BEACH,
WHERE YOU CAN SIP A DAIQUIRI
AND LAY ALL DAY
ON A PADDED CHAIR.
NOWADAYS,
IF YOU WANNA BE A TOP MODEL,
YOU REALLY HAVE TO BE
A JACK-OF-ALL-TRADES.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO TODAY
IS SORT OF PREPARE YOU GUYS
FOR THAT KIND OF WORK.
>> I'VE HAD A LOT OF PROBLEMS
WITH MY TALKING.
LIKE, MY SPANISH ACCENT
WAS REALLY BAD.
>> SO HAVE A SEAT.
>> I FEEL LIKE I WANNA TALK--
I WANNA TALK GOOD.
>> THERE ARE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF INTERVIEWS THAT YOU CAN
ENCOUNTER.
SO ONE TYPE OF INTERVIEW
IS THE PERSON WHO
JUST DOESN'T SHUT UP.
THEY TALK TOO MUCH.
ANOTHER TYPE OF INTERVIEW
THAT YOU CAN ENCOUNTER
IS THE PERSON
THAT DOESN'T TALK AT ALL.
THEY'RE SORT OF
DEER CAUGHT IN HEADLIGHTS.
SO I'VE ACTUALLY
BROUGHT MY FRIEND GARY HERE
TO HELP TEACH YOU THOSE SKILLS.
GARY RIOTTO.
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> GARY IS AN EXPERT
IN WHAT A GOOD INTERVIEW IS
AND WHAT A GOOD INTERVIEW ISN'T.
>> I KNOW HOW TO TALK TO PEOPLE
ABOUT ANYTHING
BECAUSE I'M FEARLESS
AND I HAVE A LOT TO SAY.
>> GARY HERE IS SORT OF
GOING TO PLAY THE PART
OF THOSE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF INTERVIEWS.
HI, GARY. WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> HI. HOW ARE YOU?
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE.
I'M SO EXCITED.
I CAN'T TELL YOU.
I'M, LIKE, I'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT IT ALL DAY, AND I'M JUST,
LIKE, I WAS LITERALLY JUMPING
UP AND DOWN THIS MORNING
WHEN I WAS THINKING I WAS GONNA
GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
AND SIT HERE ON THIS SET
WITH YOU RIGHT NOW...
>> OKAY.
>> THAT I'M ACTUALLY--
>> THIS IS WHAT NOT TO DO.
YOU WANNA TAKE THE END
OF WHATEVER THEY'RE SAYING
AND SEGUE IT INTO SOMETHING NEW.
READY?
>> SURE!
WOW, I'M GONNA GET TO BE
ON THE SET WITH HER.
SHE'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
THIS IS REALLY INCREDIBLE.
I'M SO LUCKY. I'M GONNA--
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT, GARY?
I'M JUST AS EXCITED
TO HAVE YOU HERE AS WELL
BECAUSE--
OKAY, DO YOU GUYS KIND OF SEE
WHAT I'M SAYING?
ANOTHER TYPE OF INTERVIEW IS
THE SUBJECT
THAT DOESN'T TALK ENOUGH.
SO, UH, ARE YOU EXCITED
TO BE HERE?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE
WHATEVER QUESTIONS YOU ASK THEM
ARE STORY STARTERS.
THEY CAN'T ANSWER THEM
WITH A 1-WORD ANSWER.
YOU GUYS FEEL LIKE
IT'S SOMETHING YOU COULD DO NOW?
YOU READY TO...
>> MM-HMM.
>> I'M SCARED.I DON'T
INTERVIEW PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW, LIKE...
I'M THE TYPE OF PERSON
WHERE, LIKE,
I LOSE MY WORDS AT TIMES.
I JUST GO BLANK.
>> JASLENE, I WANT YOU
TO BE THE HOST,
SO IT'S THE JASLENE SHOW.
YOU'LL BE THE GUEST.
>> UM, HOW HAVE
THE TRAINING IN THIS COMPETITION
MADE YOU IMPROVE IN THE
COMPETITION?
>> I'VE BEEN MORE AWARE
OF, LIKE, WHERE THE CAMERAS ARE
WHEN YOU'RE ON SET.
(crickets chirping)
>> LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH DEAD AIR,
AND THAT'S DEATH FOR TELEVISION.
>> (laughs)
>> AND YOU KNOW HOW YOU CAME UP
EMPTY?
YOU RAN OUT OF QUESTIONS TO ASK?
JUST CREATE SOMETHING
OUT OF THAT, GO,
"WOW, I'M SO MESMERIZED
BY WHAT YOU'RE SHARING WITH ME
THAT I ACTUALLY
JUST LOST MY LAST QUESTION."
>> I WOULD MAKE THE BEST
CORRESPONDENT,
I WOULD FIGURE,
BECAUSE I HAVE THE LOOK
AND I'M ABLE TO TALK.
>> HOW DID IT FEEL
TO BE IN THE HOUSE AND INTERACT
WITH ALLTHISGIRLS?
>> IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT,
YOU KNOW?
>> SO IT WAS TOUGH.
OKAY, LET'S PRETEND
THAT YOU'VE BEEN ELIMINATED.
WHO DO YOU THINK GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
>> OKAY, FIRST, I DON'T BELIEVE
I WILL BE ELIMINATED NEXT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU ARE DOING
IN THE COMPETITION,
AND HOW DO YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO DO?
>> GREAT.
IN THE BEGINNING, I WAS CALLED,
LIKE, ALMOST THE LAST ONE,
AND I FEEL VERY--
>> RIGHT, AND I REMEMBER WHEN WE
FIRST
WENT INTO THE COMPETITION...
>> YEAH, I DIDN'T--
>> YOU WERE ON THE BOTTOM.
>> I DIDN'T--I DIDN'T
END MY SENTENCE.
I WAS, UH, UNCOMFORTABLE BEFORE.
>> I THINK YOU BOTH FEEL
EQUALLY CONFIDENT.
I'M SENSING A PING-PONG HERE.
>> AND ALSO,
YOU'RE TALKING TO SOMEONE,
BUT YOU DON'T WANT TO GET
SO ENGAGED THAT YOU'RE NOT
OPENED OUT TO CAMERA.
>> HI, JAEL.
TELL ME, UM, WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
WENT TO THE AUDITIONS,
HOW WAS IT?
I MEAN, LIKE, WERE YOU SCARED?
WERE YOU NERVOUS?
>> I'M NEVER SCARED.
I'M NEVER NERVOUS.
I'M COMPLETELY FEARLESS.
I AM THE QUEEN OF THE WORLD...
>> (laughs)
>> AND I AM GOING TO KICK
ALL OF YOUR BUTTS.
>> JAEL--THIS GIRL,
SHE BLABS ABOUT
ANY AND EVERY THING.
>> LIVING IN THE HOUSE,
YOU HAVE OBTAINED RELATIONSHIPS
THAT ARE SEMI-FAMILY-LIKE
WITH THE OTHER GIRLS?
>> NO.
>> HAVE YOU MADE ANY FRIENDS?
>> YES, I'VE MADE FRIENDS,
BUT NOT AS, LIKE,
I WOULD SAY FAMILY FRIENDS.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU ARE GOING TO DO
TO SET YOURSELF APART
FROM THE OTHER GIRLS?
>> I'VE ALREADY DONE THAT.
I'VE ALREADY
ADOPTED THE NAME "BROWN."
>> DIONNE AND JAEL ARE HAVING
A REALLY, REALLY HOT TALK.
WHEN I LOOK AT THEM,
I IMAGINE TWO CATS
ARE READY TO JUMP ON EACH OTHER.
>> FEEL LIKE YOU DESERVE
TO BE HERE?
>> HELL, YEAH, I FEEL LIKE
I DESERVE TO BE HERE,
AND I KNOW I DESERVE TO BE HERE.
>> WELL, YOU HAVEN'T
WON THE CONTEST YET, SO...
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS INTERVIEW'S
GETTING A LITTLE HOT!
>> WHOO!
>> IT'S A HOT INTERVIEW!
>> A LITTLE BIT COMBATIVE.
>> WHEN YOU ARE INTERVIEWING,
YOU WERE PLAYING A ROLE
A LITTLE BIT.
IT WAS JUST SLIGHTLY AFFECTED.
>> ALL GARY'S REALLY SAYING
IS, LIKE, YOU KNOW, BE YOURSELF.
DON'T PRETEND--THIS IS
WHAT A HOST WOULD SOUND LIKE.
OKAY, GIRLS, SO THINK ABOUT
WHAT YOU'VE LEARNED TODAY,
BECAUSE TOMORROW,
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
YOUR CHALLENGE.
>> THIS TEACH, I THINK,
IS GONNA LEAD
TO SOME CRAZY MUMBO JUMBO
THAT WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT WE'RE IN STORE FOR.
(water splashing)
(laughter)
>> ALL THE GIRLS IN THE HOUSE
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO ME.
I LOVE IT HERE.
>> JAEL AND I
HAD DIFFERENCES IN THE PAST,
BUT IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
KIND OF LIKE, OKAY,
WE CAN SEPARATE AND VENT.
I'M GONNA KISS YOU.
(laughs)
(speaks indistinctly)
NOW WE'RE BACK ON TRACK,
AND I'M JUST KIND OF
LETTING JAEL BE JAEL.
>> YEAH, I GOT KISSED, BITCHES.
EAT YOUR HEARTS OUT.
>> BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF SHE HAS WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A MODEL.
>> (laughs)
♪♪♪
>> HI, GIRLS.
IT WAS GREAT
SEEING ALL OF YOU YESTERDAY.
I HOPE YOU HAD A LOT OF FUN.
I HAD AN AWESOME TIME
TEACHING YOU EVERYTHING
THAT I'VE LEARNED
ABOUT CORRESPONDING.
AND TODAY WE'RE GONNA
GIVE YOU GUYS A CHALLENGE.
I WANNA SEE IF YOU CAN
TAKE EVERYTHING
THAT I'VE TAUGHT YOU
AND HIT THE STREETS WITH IT.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> LIKE I WAS SAYING, GIRLS...
>> YOU'RE GOING
TO SYDNEY, AUSTRALIA!
>> (screaming)
>> WHOO!
>> I WAS IN COMPLETE SHOCK.
AUSTRALIA!
LIKE, I'VE NEVER BEEN
NOWHERE ELSE BESIDES THE HOOD
AND AROUND THE CORNER.
>> (cheering)
>> THE AMAZING THING ABOUT TYRA
IS SHE CAN HAVE ON THE RATTIEST,
TORN-UP KANGAROO COSTUME,
AND STILL LOOK
ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
IT'S REALLY AWESOME TO SEE
THE HUMAN SIDE OF TYRA.
>> YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE DOING
THIS CORRESPONDENT'S JOB
IN AUSTRALIA.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MILES AWAY
THAT IS.
>> AAH!MY GOD!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> (screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WOW, YOU DIDN'T--
YOU DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS SAYING?
>> NO! (laughs)
>> DELAYED REACTION.
WE'RE GOING TO AUSTRALIA!
>> OH!
>> AAH!
>> I WAS SO EXCITED.
I WAS JUMPING AROUND.
IT WAS LIKE, OH, MY GOD,
AUSTRALIA!
>> THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE,
THIS CORRESPONDING IS GOING
TO AIR ON THE TYRA SHOW...
>> OH!
>> AND YOU'RE GONNA BE A
TYRA SHOW CORRESPONDENT
MORE THAN ONCE.
>> OH!
(screaming)
>> NEXT TIME I SEE YOU GUYS,
IT'LL BE G'DAY.
>> ♪ AUSTRALIA ♪
>> ♪ HOP TO IT ♪
>> ♪ AUSTRALIA! ♪
♪♪♪
>> "SYDNEY FASHION
CAN BE BEST DESCRIBED
AS BODY-CONSCIOUS.
AUSTRALIAN DESIGNERS..."
IT'S LIKE A MOUSE WITH A TAIL.
>> (shrieks)
>> I'VE NEVER TRAVELED
OVERSEAS BEFORE,
AND WE ALL GET TO GO TOGETHER,
SO IT'S KIND OF LIKE
A BUNCH OF GIRLFRIENDS
WINNING A FREE TRIP
TO AUSTRALIA.
>> AUSTRALIA--
LIKE, I'VE NEVER BEEN NOWHERE.
I'M GONNA HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF GOING TO ANOTHER COUNTRY...
>> BYE, HOUSE.
>> SEE OTHER PEOPLE,
AND CONTINUE ON
IN THE JOURNEY OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
(didgeridoo playing)
>> WE ARRIVE IN SYDNEY,
AND I WAS SO EXCITED
TO COME TO AUSTRALIA.
YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY HAS A DREAM
TO GO TO JAPAN.
SOMEBODY IS CRAZY ABOUT
THE TIBET.
I WAS CRAZY ABOUT AUSTRALIA.
>> G'DAY,
MY NAME'S ERIKA HEYNATZ.
I'M A MODEL, TV PRESENTER,
AND WAS ALSO THE ORIGINAL HOST
OF "AUSTRALIA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME AUSTRALIA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU GUYS MUST BE
ABSOLUTELY KNACKERED
AFTER A LONG HAUL
FROM THE UNITED STATES.
AS AN INTERNATIONAL TOP MODEL,
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE
TO WALK STRAIGHT OFF THE PLANE
AND LITERALLY
RIGHT ONTO LOCATION.
I KNOW TYRA HAS SENT YOU HERE
ON ASSIGNMENT,
SO NO MUCKINGAROUND.
WE'RE GONNA GET STUCK STRAIGHT
INTO THE HARD YAKKA.
I'M GONNA SEND YOU OFF
TO HAVE A CRACK
AT CHEWING THE FAT
WITH THE LOCALS.
(crickets chirping)
>> (laughs)
YOU GUYS HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT, DO YOU?
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> THAT'S BECAUSE I'M
TALKING TO YOU
IN TRUE-BLUE AUSSIE SLANG.
>> I HAD
THE BIGGEST QUESTION MARK
ON MY FOREHEAD.
LIKE, I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
A WORD.
>> AND YOUR CHALLENGE FOR TODAY
IS YOU'RE GONNA DO A
BUNCH OF INTERVIEWS.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO INCORPORATE
AS MUCH AUSSIE SLANG
INTO THOSE INTERVIEWS
AS POSSIBLE.
YOUR SUBJECT WILL BE
AMERICAN FASHION FAUX PAS.
THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
WILL BE A CORRESPONDENT
ON THE TYRA SHOW.
>> (mouths word)
>> GOOD LUCK, GIRLS,
AND MAKE SURE EACH YARN
IS A GOOD ONE.
HERE IS THE AUSSIE SLANG BIBLE.
PUT IT TO GOOD USE
DURING YOUR INTERVIEWS.
>> I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
ABOUT THE CHALLENGE
BECAUSE OF MY SHORT-TERM MEMORY.
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL,
I GOT RUN OVER BY A CAR...
HAD EIGHT STAPLES IN MY HEAD,
AND IT AFFECTED
THE MEMORY PART OF MY BRAIN.
>> "MAD AS A CUT SNAKE."
(laughs)
>> PUT ALL THE SKILLS
THAT APRIL TAUGHT US...
>> RIGHT. RIGHT, RIGHT.
I-I UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> I'M NOT AT ALL
READY FOR THIS CHALLENGE
BECAUSE IT'S, LIKE, WE DIDN'T
EVEN GET A CHANCE TO REST.
WE GOT NO SLEEP ON THE PLANE.
YOU'RE ASKING US TO GO OUT
AND INTERVIEW PEOPLE?
>> GOOD AVRO.
IT'S RENEE, HERE IN
BEAUTIFUL SYDNEY, AUSTRALIA,
ON BONDI BEACH.
HI.
OKAY, SO I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE IT'S OKAY
TO WEAR THONGS WITH, UH,
AN EXY OUTFIT?
>> PROBABLY NOT.
>> WOULD YOU PREFER TO SEE
A YANK WOMAN
WITH HER UNDERWEAR SHOWING
UP OVER TOP OF HER JEANS?
>> UNDIES ARE UNDIES.
YOU KEEP 'EM WITHIN YOUR PANTS.
>> THE NEXT THING
THAT I WANNA ASK YOU IS
WHAT IS, LIKE, THE THING
THAT YOU HATE THE MOST
ABOUT AMERICAN FASHION?
>> IT'S QUITE BRIGHT AND LOUD.
>> OKAY, THAT'S COOL.
THAT'S COOL.
WELL, LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
SO YOU'RE FROM ENGLAND, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> OKAY, WELL, THAT'S COOL.
THAT'S COOL. SO...
>> I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU. FIRST--
>> NICE OUTFIT, BY THE WAY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
AUSSIE WOMEN HAVE
THAT US YANKS DO NOT?
>> THE PEOPLE AT THE GIRL--
AT THE BEACH MIGHT, YOU KNOW,
GO TOPLESS MORE OFTEN.
>> I'M ALL ABOUT THAT.
>> YOU'RE ALL ABOUT THAT?
>> ALL RIGHT, WHERE ARE YOU
FROM?
>> I'M FROM THE UNITED STATES.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT
THE MAJOR FASHION FAUX PAS ARE?
>> WOMEN WEARING SKIMPY TOPS
WHERE THEIR BRA STRAPS
ARE SHOWING.
>> OH, NO.
>> MY NAME IS JASLENE.
IT'S MY PLEASURE.
>> DO YOU HAVE DAKS ON?
>> YES, I DO.
>> COULD I SEE THEM?
OOH, THEY'RE GRAY!
THAT WAS NICE.
>> (laughs)
>> YOU WERE A DAG.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UM...
>> YOU WERE A DAG,
AND I LOVED IT.
>> SO, UH, WHAT DO YOU THINK--
DO YOU WEAR A LIPPY?
>> NO.
>> NO. COOL. HE DOES NOT.
TELL ME, WHAT--WHAT DOES
THE METROSEXSUAL MEN WEAR
WHEN HE IS CRACKED ON SOMEBODY?
>> HMM.
>> DON'T BE CACTUS. JUST TALK.
I'M JUST EARBASHING PERSON
RIGHT HERE,
AND YOU GUYS ALL CACTUSES.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK
THAT AUSSIE WOMEN HAVE
THAT AMERICAN YANKS DO NOT?
>> UM, SEX APPEAL.
>> I THINK THAT
I'M REALLY GOOD AT SPEAKING
WITH OTHER HUMAN BEINGS,
AND I WAS DRESSED TO IMPRESS.
>> THE NEXT THING
THAT I WANNA ASK YOU--
ARE YOU, LIKE, ANTIFUR?
>> I DON'T WEAR FUR AT ALL.
>> OKAY, WELL, THAT'S COOL.
THAT'S COOL.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU--
WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT METROSEXUALITY HERE?
>> IT'S GREAT.
THE GUYS JUST WEAR
WHATEVER THEY WANT, AND...
>> THAT'S COOL. THAT'S COOL.
SO WE'RE JUST
WRAPPING IT UP HERE WITH JULIE.
SO BACK TO YOU, TYRA.
>> HEY! HERE THEY ARE!
>> HI!
>> HOW DID MY NEW
AUSSIE RECRUITS GO?
>> GOOD.
>> (laughs)
>> YOU MUST BE KNACKERED
AFTER SUCH A LONG DAY.
UNFORTUNATELY,
YOU WON'T FIND OUT
THE WINNER OF THE CHALLENGE
UNTIL YOUR NEXT PANEL.
YOU DO DESERVE SOME REST.
YOU'VE WORKED PRETTY HARD TODAY,
AND THE VERY LAST THING
THAT I HAVE TO GIVE YOU...
(grunts)
>> YEAH!
>> AAH!
>> IF YOU THINK THIS
KEY LOOKS BIG,
YOU SHOULD SEE
THE SIZE OF YOUR NEW APARTMENT.
(laughter)
♪♪♪
>> OH!
>> WE ARRIVE TO OUR APARTMENT.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
IT'S ALL DECKED OUT
AUSSIE STYLE.
IT'S REALLY FUN.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> AND WE HAVE PICTURES
OF MY GIRL, CARIDEE,
ALL OVER THE HOUSE.
JUST TO SEE HER
AND LOOK AT HER PICTURES...
YOU KNOW, SHE WON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> (laughs)
I'M A COVERGIRL MODEL.
I'M GONNA BE ON THE COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE.
(crying) WHERE'S MY ALARM CLOCK?
I NEED TO WAKE UP.
>> I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SIX OF US,
BUT ONLY ONE'S GONNA BE
A WINNER.
IT'S THE BREAKPOINT
OF THE COMPETITION
WHERE YOU HAVE TO GET SERIOUS.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I'VE BEEN DOING MEDIOCRE.
>> I'VE BEEN IN THE BOTTOM TWO
TWICE NOW.
>> WILL KATHLEEN AND JAEL
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
WILL JAEL AND WHITNEY
>> I'M ALWAYS IN THE FINAL TWO.
THAT'S FINE...
AS LONG AS I GET TO STAY.
>> THE ONLY PEOPLE
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN IN THE
BOTTOM THREE...
>> ARE YOU...
>> IS ME AND BRITTANY.
>> WE'RE IN AUSTRALIA.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
I THINK I CAN HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I THINK I STILL HAVE
A LITTLE BIT TO LEARN.
♪♪♪
>> (singsong voice) WE GOT
SOME TYRA MAIL!
(normal voice) NATASHA?
>> WERE YOU HIDING AGAIN?
>> "G'DAY!
GET READY TO PUT UP YOUR DUKES.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> KANGAROOS!
>> YEAH!
>> WHY KANGAROOS?
>> (laughs)
>> BOXING KANGAROOS.
>> OH.
♪♪♪
>> HEY! HOW YOU GUYS DOING?
>> (laughs)
>> OUTBACK IN AUSTRALIA.
BUT NOW LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
SO SINCE YOU'VE LANDED,
I'M SURE YOU GUYS HAVE
HAD THE CHANCE TO CHAT
WITH SOME LOCAL AUSSIES, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> BUT HAVE YOU REALLY
BEEN LISTENING TO THEIR ACCENTS?
'CAUSE TODAY
YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA BE DOING
A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL,
BUT WITH
A THICK AUSTRALIAN ACCENT.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> ALL RIGHT?
>> I'M VERY NERVOUS
ABOUT THIS CHALLENGE
BECAUSE I HAVE AN ACCENT,
AND I HAVE TO PUT
THE AUSSIE ACCENT
ON TOP OF MY RUSSIAN ACCENT.
>> NOW LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT THE CREATIVE'S GONNA BE.
WE'RE GONNA SHOOT THIS IN PIECES
AND PUT IT TOGETHER LATER.
BASICALLY,
THERE IS A PHOTOGRAPHER
WAITING FOR A KANGAROO
TO COME BY SO HE CAN SNAP THAT
SHOT.
BUT THEN YOU GIRLS SHOW UP
WITH YOUR DRAMATIC EYES,
FEATURING
THE VolumeExact MASCARA
AND THE QUEEN COLLECTION
SHADOWS,
AND THAT TOTALLY DISTRACTS HIM,
SO HE STARTS SHOOTING YOU GUYS.
SO BASICALLY,
YOU'VE DISTRACTED THE GUY
FROM HIS JOB
BECAUSE YOU LOOK SO GORGEOUS
AS THESE BEAUTIFUL COVER GIRLS.
SO LET'S GO TO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
AND I'LL GIVE YOU GUYS YOUR
SCRIPTS IN THERE.
>> TELL ME MORE ABOUT THE
PRODUCT.
>> (imitating Australian accent)
...Exact MASCARA,
WITH ITS REVOLUTIONARY BRUSH.
>> (all speaking indistinctly)
>> WAS THAT GOOD?
>> "I WISH I COULD CAPTURE..."
>> (imitates Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD...
>> "CAP-CHAR."
>> CAP-CHAR. CAP-CHAR.
>> CAP-CHAR.
>> CAP-CHAR, RATHER THAN...
(imitates British accent)
COP-TURE.
>> I WISH I COULD... I WISH...
>> I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
BECAUSE MY SHORT-TERM MEMORY
EFFECTS ME A LITTLE BIT.
IT JUST TAKES PRACTICE AND TIME.
>> RENEE.
>> HI, JAY.
>> THIS IS NICK, WHO IS GONNA
PLAY YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY.
>> QUIET, PLEASE!
>> REMEMBER WHAT I ALWAYS
TELL YOU--GO OVER-THE-TOP,
LET ME PULL YOU BACK.
SO WHATEVER YOU WERE GONNA DO,
YOUR "CROCODILE HUNTER,"
GO FOR IT.
>> I WILL. (laughs)
>> ROLL CAMERA.
>> SAY "TAKE ONE,"
TAKE A BREAK AND THEN GO.
>> TAKE ONE.
>> ACTION.
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
THE NEW... (laughs)
>> OKAY, LET'S GO AGAIN.
THIS IS GOOD.
>> I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
THE NEW...
>> OKAY, WE BRING CUE CARDS IN,
AND WE CAN HAVE THEM
NEXT TO THE LENS.
IT'S GONNA BE THERE
TO HELP YOU OUT.
>> HETHINKS
I'M THE MOST BEAUTIFUL SHEILA
HE'S EVER SEEN IN THE BUSH.
NOW THAT'S EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
(bell dings)
>> GOOD JOB, RENEE!
OKAY, WE'RE GONNA DO
SOME REACTION SHOTS...
>> (normal voice) OKAY.
>> THAT WE NEED TO EDIT
INTO THE COMMERCIAL.
SO SMILING, SMILING...
NOW WHAT WOULD QUEEN DO?
LOOK UP INTO QUEEN.
WE'RE GONNA PUT A BIG BUBBLE
ABOVE YOUR HEAD, AND WE'RE GONNA
PUT QUEEN LATIFAH IN THE BUBBLE.
>> (laughs)
>> SO YOU'RE GONNA PRETEND LIKE
YOU'RE TAKING SOME EYE
SHADOW OFF,
AND YOU'RE GONNA GO, "OH!"
OKAY, ROLL. WRAP IT ON RENEE.
>> ROLL CAMERA, AND ACTION.
>> I WISH I CAN BRING...
(whines) OH, JAY.
>> AGAIN.
>> (imitating Australian accent)
WHAT WOULD QUEEN DO?
PLUMP 'EM, NOT CLUMP 'EM, GIRL.
(normal voice) WHEN I START
TO SPIT MY LINES, I JUST GO,
WHAT? WHAT IS MY LINE?
I-I CAN'T REMEMBER IT!
TAKE 16.
(imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MYLOOK.
NEW QUEEN COLORS DO JUST THAT.
>> I THOUGHT WHEN DIONNE
WALKED ONTO THE SET... WOW.
BUT DIONNE'S PERFORMANCE
SOUNDED LIKE
ONE RUN-ON SENTENCE.
>> NEW EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
(sheep bleats)
(rooster clucks)
>> THE BEST THING
ABOUT BEING AT THIS SHOOT
IS THAT I'M SURROUNDED BY NATURE
AND I'M FINALLY AT HOME,
AND I GET TO RUN FREE.
DON'T LAUGH.
>> I'M NOT GONNA LAUGH.
>> I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
REAL HARD.
>> HERE'S THE BEST
PIECE OF ADVICE--
MAKE THIS AS CONVERSATIONAL
AS POSSIBLE.
TALK TO SOMEONE.
>> QUIET, EVERYWHERE.
>> TAKE ONE!
(laughs)
(imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
NEW QUEEN SHADOWS
WILL DO JUST THAT.
>> THAT'S GOOD. LET IT OUT.
NOW JUST SAY "TAKE TWO."
>> (normal voice) DOING
THE COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL
WAS A BIT OVER-THE-TOP
IN FAKE HAPPINESS FOR ME,
AND IT'S DEFINITELY DIFFICULT.
I CAN DO THIS
AND I'M GONNA GET THROUGH THIS,
AND I'M GONNA
TRY REALLY HARD THIS TIME.
TAKE 13.
(imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
NEW QUEEN SHADOWS
CAN DO JUST THAT.
>> TALK TO SOMEBODY.
LOOK, WHEN I TALK TO YOU,
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF I WENT,
"JAEL... OKAY.
THAT'S WHAT WE'LL DO."
I LOVED JAEL'S ENERGY,
BUT I THINK WE REALLY STRUGGLED
TO GET A GOOD LINE READ
OUT OF JAEL.
>> (normal voice) TAKE 23.
THE VIBRANT COLOR WILL BRING
IN...
WILL ILLUMINATE...
(normal voice) WAS IT BETTER?
>> (laughs) OKAY,
WE'RE GONNA DO THESE.
THESE WILL PROBABLY
BE EASIER FOR YOU.
SO YOU PUT ON YOUR EYE SHADOW
AND SMILE
AND LOOK BACK AT CAMERA.
OH, YOU CANNOT SMILE LIKE THAT.
>> (laughs)
OKAY, JAEL, I WOULDN'T USE THAT
BECAUSE IT'S JUST SO...
HEY! OH! OH!
YOU WANT PEOPLE AT HOME
TO BUY THE PRODUCT.
IF YOU SAW YOURSELF ON THE FILM,
YOU LOOKED GORGEOUS.
OH, BUT, AND--AND I SEE
YOU'RE TEARING UP.
I KNOW IT'S HARD.
IF I DON'T PREP YOU
AND GIVE YOU THE HARSH REALITY
OF WHERE IT IS NOW,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET
TO THAT END RESULT.
>> I FEEL LIKE SUCH AN IDIOT.
'CAUSE I'M NOT
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR,
AND I'M NOT, LIKE, BUBBLY
AND ALL THAT.
I JUST WANNA, LIKE,
TOUCH THE GRASS AND THE ANIMALS
AND, LIKE, BREATHE THE AIR
AND CLIMB THE TREES.
(sighs) WHY DIDN'T YOU TELL ME
THAT I WAS GONNA GO UP THERE
AND EMBARRASS MYSELF?
>> WHAT?
>> YOU KNOW!
>> I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING!
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> UGH.
>> I TOLD YOU IT WAS A CHALLENGE
FOR EVERYBODY.
>> I WANNA BE UP THERE
DRESSED IN ALL BLACK LEATHER,
WHIPPING SOME BOY'S ASS.
(imitates whip cracking)
WHEN'S THAT PHOTO SHOOT?
>> SHE HAD US DO IT
LIKE THE WAY WE SEE NOW.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHY
I LOVE HER HAIR LIKE THIS?
HER HAIR, HER MAKEUP,
HER OUTFIT...
>> ALL OF IT.
>> IS JANICE DICKINSON...
>> AY! (laughs)
>> FROM THE SERENGETI DESERT.
IT'S GENIUS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> OKAY, ROLL CAMERA,
AND ACTION.
>> (imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
NEW QUEEN SHADOWS
HAVE DONE JUST THAT.
THE VIBRANT COLORS...
(normal voice) TAKE TWO.
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
>> IT'S OKAY.
DON'T LET IT DEFEAT YOU.
>> (normal voice) TAKE SIX.
(imitating Australian accent)
THE NEW VolumeExact MASCARA,
WITH ITS REVOLUTIONARY BRUSH,
WILL DO THE TRICK.
I GET THE VOLUME
WITHOUT THE CLUMPS.
>> EVEN THOUGH JASLENE
WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS AT FIRST,
ON HER SIXTH TAKE,
JASLENE NAILED THE ENTIRE SCRIPT
WITHOUT CUE CARDS,
AND THAT WAS REALLY DIFFICULT.
>> I WAS EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
>> GOT THE LINES DOWN?
>> I THINK I HAVE 'EM DOWN.
I HOPE I HAVE 'EM DOWN.
>> YOU'LL DO FINE. YOU'RE GOOD.
>> MY MEMORY SUCKS.
>> SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'VE SHOT A LOT OF OUR SHOTS,
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
INTERCUT THIS.
AND SO WHAT I NEED FROM YOU
IS YOUR WHOLE READ--
YOUR WHOLE SCRIPT,
AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS--
UH-OH, YOU LOOK NERVOUS.
>> WELL, I GOT HIT BY A CAR
WHEN I WAS 17,
SO MY MEMORY'S
A LITTLE... FROM THAT, SO...
>> OKAY.
WELL, YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SOMETIMES LEARN
TO WORK THROUGH...
>> ...YOUR SHORTCOMINGS
IF THIS IS WHAT YOU WANNA DO.
>> AND ACTION.
>> TAKE ONE.
(imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE...
(blows raspberry)
(normal voice) SORRY. TAKE TWO.
(imitates Australian accent)
I WISH... (groans)
(normal voice) THIS IS AWKWARD.
>> DON'T--DON'T GET NERVOUS.
>> DON'T THINK ABOUT IT.
>> REMEMBER, DON'T
THINK ABOUT IT.
>> I KNOW. TAKE SIX.
(imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE AUSTRALIAN...
AUSTRALIAN OUTBACK.
(normal voice) OUTBACK.
>> NOW IF IT MAKES YOU FEEL
ANY BETTER,
WE'LL GIVE YOU CUE CARDS.
>> TAKE 16.
(imitating Australian accent)
DON'T CLUMP 'EM, GIRL.
NEW VolumeExact...
(mouths words)
(normal voice) TRYING TO RELY ON
THE CUE CARDS
AND MY SHORT-TERM MEMORY--
IT WAS A HUGE MISTAKE ON MY PART
TO TRY TO DO THAT.
THEIR VIBRANT COLORS
ADDS INTENSITY TO MY EYES...
(normal voice) I SUCK AT THIS.
>> IF YOU LET IT
OVERTAKE YOU EMOTIONALLY--
'CAUSE I CAN SEE YOUR TEARS
COMING IN YOUR EYES
AND EVERYTHING--
THAT'S--IT'S JUST
GONNA DEFEAT YOU.
OKAY?
COULD WE GET MAKEUP IN HERE,
JUST WITH SOME TISSUES?
>> (mouths word)
>> UM, THAT'S OKAY.
>> (crying) IT'S JUST
FRUSTRATING TO HAVE SOMETHING
THAT STILL AFFECTS ME, LIKE,
FIVE YEARS LATER.
I MEAN, LIKE,
I COULD LOOK AT THE CUE CARD,
READ IT AND FORGET
WHAT WAS ON THE CUE CARD
IN TWO--TWO SECONDS.
AND IT'S HARD TO ACT LIKE,
"DEE-DEE-DEE!"
WHEN YOU'RE AGGRAVATED.
TAKE 29.
(imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK...
(voice breaks) IN MY LOOK.
NEW QUEEN SHADOWS
HAVE DONE JUST THAT.
>> THE PROBLEM THAT I HAD
WITH BRIT'S PERFORMANCE
WAS THE FACT
THAT BRIT WAS TOTALLY OVERCOME
BY THAT EMOTIONAL SCAR
AND THAT BAGGAGE.
>> HE THINKS
I'M THE MOST BEAUTIFUL SHEILA...
HE'S SEEN IN THE BUSH.
NOW THAT'S EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
>> SHE GOT
REALLY, REALLY FRUSTRATED
WITH HERSELF,
AND THEREFORE,
IT TOTALLY SHATTERED
HER PERFORMANCE.
>> CAN I USE MY HANDS RIGHT HERE
OR IS BETTER...
>> NO, YOU CAN DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
YOU'RE IN...WE'RE DOING IT IN
HERE.
>> ROLLING, AND ACTION.
>> TAKE ONE.
(imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
NEW QUEEN SHADOWS
HAVE DONE JUST THAT.
>> THIS IS HOW YOU'RE STANDING
RIGHT NOW.
"I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE OUTBACK IN MY LOOK..."
LOOKING LIKE AN APE.
>> I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
>> HAVE FUN WITH IT
FROM THE TOP.
DON'T DO THIS...
(imitating speaking in Russian)
>> (laughing)
>> (normal voice) LIKE,
I'M FEELING LIKE THIS
IS A RUSSIAN PANTOMIME
OR SOMETHING.
>> (normal voice) ENGLISH
IS MY SECOND LANGUAGE.
THAT'S WHY IT WAS HARDER FOR ME
THAN TO ANY OF THIS GIRLS
TO REMEMBER THE LINES.
>> I WANT THAT EASY,
BREEZY NATURE
FROM THE BEGINNING.
>> TAKE NINE.
(imitating Australian accent)
G'DAY, MATE!
HE THINKS
I'M THE MOST BEAUTIFUL SHEILA
HE'S EVER SEEN IN THE BUSH.
NOW THAT'S EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
>> GENIUS!
I WOULDN'T SAY
THAT WAS AN AUSTRALIAN ACCENT,
BUT YOU GOT THROUGH IT,
YOU DELIVERED IT.
CIRCLE IT. LET'S MOVE ON.
>> (normal voice) AW, YEAH!
I FEEL BLOODY GOOD, MATE,
ABOUT MY COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
(normal voice) THANK YOU
SO MUCH! (laughing)
>> THANK YOU.
>> MEMORIZING THAT...
>> YOU GUYS, OH, MY GOD.
(laughs)
>> AND, LIKE,
I HAD IT ALL MEMORIZED,
AND THEN, LIKE, I THINK WHEN
THEY BROUGHT IN THE CUE CARDS,
LIKE, IT TOTALLY, LIKE...
YOU KNOW?
>> I DON'T WANT, LIKE,
ANYBODY TO GO.
>> I KNOW.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GO HOME,
AND I'M NOT FINISHED
SPREADING THE JOY
TO THE UNIVERSE.
>> BUT YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT
THE JUDGES ARE GONNA SAY.
THEY MAY LOOK AT IT
AND ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
THEY MAY LOOK AT MINE
AND GO, LIKE,
WHAT THE HELL WERE YOU THINKING?
LIKE, DO CRAZY
CROCODILE HUNTER-STYLE?
>> WHAT'S THE MATTER, BRITTANY?
>> YOU WERE SO GORGEOUS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW YOU--
HOW YOU DONE.
>> I FEEL LIKE I DID MY BEST,
AND I'M NOT THAT UPSET
WITH THAT.
I'M JUST UPSET BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, FIVE YEARS LATER,
AND, LIKE, I REALIZE
THAT IT SUCKS.
♪♪♪
>> G'DAY, LADIES!
WELCOME TO AUSTRALIA.
ISN'T IT LOVELY HERE?
>> YEAH, AMAZING!
>> WELCOME TO THE JUDGING ROOM.
FINAL SIX.
HOLLA! CAN I GET A HANDS UP?
>> YEAH!
>> WHOO-HOO!
>> HOLLA.
YOU GUYS KNOW THE PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
A 6-PAGE SPREAD AND A COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND HERE ARE OUR JUDGES
DOWN UNDER.
THE FIRST IS MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
DIVA RUNWAY COACH
EXTRAORDINAIRE...
TWIGGY,
FASHION ICON AND LIVING LEGEND.
AND YOU SEE
OUR GUEST JUDGE HERE--
ERIKA HEYNATZ.
SHE IS SUPERMODEL
AND THE ORIGINAL HOST
OF "AUSTRALIA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN,
GIRLS.
>> HI.
>> I GOTTA TELL YOU,
I LOVE INTRODUCING YOU,
BECAUSE "TOP MODEL"
WAS JUST THIS IDEA THAT WE HAD
THAT WE THOUGHT
WOULD BE IN AMERICA,
BUT NOW IT'S IN
OVER 120 COUNTRIES.
>> IT'S A HUGE SUCCESS HERE.
>> NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE WILL DETERMINE
WHICH OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED.
NATASHA, YOU'RE FIRST.
>> G'DAY, MATES.
>> G'DAY.
>> SO THIS WEEK, YOUR ASSIGNMENT
WAS TO INTERVIEW PEOPLE
ALL ACROSS SYDNEY,
AND THE WINNER
WOULD BE A CORRESPONDENT
ON "THE TYRA BANKS SHOW."
AND AT THE END OF JUDGING,
I'LL ANNOUNCE WHO THE WINNER IS.
ALL RIGHT, SO ALL OF YOU GIRLS
HAD TO SHOOT
A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL
WHERE YOU HAD TO SELL PRODUCT
AND DO IT WITH AN AUSSIE ACCENT.
LET'S SEE HOW THE COMMERCIAL
TURNED OUT.
♪♪♪
>> I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
>> NEW QUEEN SHADOWS
HAVE DONE JUST THAT.
>> THE VIBRANT COLORS
BRING INTENSITY TO MY EYES.
>> AND NOW ON TO MY LASHES.
WHAT WOULD QUEEN DO?
>> PLUMP 'EM,
DON'T CLUMP 'EM, GIRL.
>> THE NEW VolumeExact MASCARA,
WITH ITS REVOLUTIONARY BRUSH...
>> WILL DO THE TRICK.
I GET VOLUME WITHOUT THE CLUMPS.
(laughter)
>> G'DAY, MATE.
>> HE THINKS
I'M THE MOST BEAUTIFUL SHEILA
HE'S SEEN IN THE BUSH.
>> NOW THAT'S EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
(bell dings)
>> NICE FINISH.
>> OH, MY GOSH,
YOU GUYS LOOKED GREAT!
ALL RIGHT, NATASHA,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST TAKE.
HE THINKS
I'M THE MOST BEAUTIFUL SHEILA
HE'S EVER SEEN IN THE BUSH.
NOW THAT'S EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL
>> NATASHA, I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT A GIRL FROM RUSSIA
WITH A HEAVY RUSSIAN ACCENT
HAS DELIVERED
SUCH A GREAT AUSSIE COMMERCIAL.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> I AM SHOCKED AND AMAZED.
YOU WEREN'T JUST ONE-NOTE.
YOU CHANGED YOUR INFLECTIONS.
>> AND SHE GOT THE COMEDY
OUT OF THE "SHEILA" LINE.
IT WAS BRILLIANT.
>> I DO FEEL LIKE YOUR POSES
WERE TOO SEXY IN THE END.
>> LIKE, YOU WRINKLED YOUR NOSE
UP.
REMEMBER I TOLD YOU
YOU DO THAT WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO BE SEXY?
JUST RELAX YOUR FACE.
THANK YOU, NATASHA.
>> THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS DIONNE.
ALL RIGHT, SO YOU HAD
A COMMERCIAL FOR COVERGIRL.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST TAKE.
>> (imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
NEW SHADOWS... UGH!
HE THINKS
I'M THE MOST BEAUTIFUL SHEILA
IN THE BUSH.
NEW EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
>> (imitates Caribbean accent)
YOU KNOW SOMETHIN', DARLIN'?
(laughter)
>> SHE ALMOST SOUND WEST INDIAN.
>> YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
WHEN THEY'RE GOING AFTER
A YOUNGER VIEWER...
(perky voice) YOU SEE HOW
I'M TALKING TO YOU RIGHT NOW?
"PLUMP 'EM,
DON'T CLUMP 'EM, GIRL,"
YOU KNOW?
LIKE, ALWAYS BE LIKE THIS,
IT'S KIND OF CAMP.
>> AND IF THE ACCENT'S BAD,
REMEMBER THAT THE KEY
WAS TO--TO HAVE
A SENSE OF HUMOR ABOUT IT.
>> ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS JASLENE. HI, JASLENE.
>> HELLO, TYRA.
(imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE THE DRAMA
OF THE OUTBACK IN MY LOOK.
NEW QUEEN SHADOWS HAVE
DONE JUST THAT.
I GET VOLUME WITHOUT...
THE CLUMP.
>> (laughs)
>> (makes whooshing sound)
>> YOU COMMITTED 100%
TO THE ACCENT, AS OFF AS IT WAS,
BUT YOU JUST WERE
THINKING TOO MUCH.
IF YOU WOULD'VE RELAXED
AND LET IT GO,
YOU WOULD'VE HAD A
STELLAR COMMERCIAL.
>> YOU'RE PROBABLY
NOT CONSCIOUS OF THE FACT
THAT YOU FROWN WHEN
YOU'RE SPEAKING, TOO.
SO YOU CAN REALLY TELL
THAT YOU--YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE IN YOUR HEAD.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR YOU TO LEARN
HOW TO GIVE EXPRESSION
AND HOW TO BE BIG, AND THERE'S
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN...
AND...
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> MM-HMM.
>> ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS RENEE.
SO, RENEE, YOU NERVOUS?
>> NO, I JUST WENT FOR, LIKE,
THE CROCODILE HUNTER STYLE.
>> WELL, MAYBE YOU'RE PAYING
SOME HOMAGE TO HIM.
SO LET'S SEE
IF YOU MADE STEVE IRWIN PROUD.
>> (imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
WHAT WOULD QUEEN DO?
PLUMP 'EM,
DON'T CLUMP 'EM, GIRL.
>> YEAH, YOU CHANNELED STEVE
IRWIN FOR REAL.
I MEAN, INCLUDING THE FACT THAT
HE WAS A MAN.
>> (laughs)
>> JUST REMEMBER
THAT YOU'RE A GIRL
AND YOU'RE SELLING MAKEUP,
NOT, LIKE... MUFFLERS.
>> SHE KEPT LEANING IN.
YOU KNOW, LIKE, SORT OF, LIKE,
WHEN YOU WERE TALKING.
AND I THINK MAYBE IF SHE
DID HAVE EYES ON THE CAMERA
SHE WOULD'VE BEEN A LITTLE MORE
SOFT AND PRETTY.
>> MM-HMM.
>> PRINCESS DIANA.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK DOWN FOR--
OH, MY GOD!
(whispers) WOW.
(normal voice) YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER
THAT YOU'RE A MODEL,
NOT JUST AN ACTRESS,
LIKE, RESPONDING.
SO YOU GOT THE ACTING GOOD
AND THAT COY...
(giggles) "HE'S SO CUTE."
BUT YOU HAVE TO MIX UP
THAT YOU'RE MODELING
AND SELLING MAKEUP
WITH "OH, MY GOD, HE'S SO CUTE.
ISN'T HE CUTE?"
>> (laughs) THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS JAEL.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST TAKE.
>> (imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
THE VIBRANT COLOR WILL...
(groans)
WHAT WOULD THE QUEEN DO?
(normal voice) WHAT WOULD
QUEEN DO?
I THINK I'M READY NOW.
(imitating Australian accent)
WHAT WOULD QUEEN DO?
PLUMP 'EM,
DON'T CLUMP 'EM, GIRL!
NOW THAT'S EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL DOING
SOMETHING
THAT'S SO LIGHT AND AIRY
AND BUBBLY AND GIRL NEXT DOOR,
WHEN YOU'RE, LIKE, ANARCHY?
>> (laughs) YEAH, LIKE,
I-I DEFINITELY, LIKE,
HAD A BIT OF CONFLICT WITH THAT.
>> YOU COULD'VE SMILED.
'CAUSE YOU ALMOST LOOK MAD.
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE,
"UGH, NOW WHAT NEXT?
NOW WHAT'S MY NEXT LINE?"
>> BUT WHAT YOU LOOKED
LIKE TO ME IS AN ANARCHIST
MAKING FUN OF BEING A COVERGIRL,
AS OPPOSED TO
BRINGING YOU INTO IT.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE, LIKE,
THIS GIRL THAT'S...
"OKAY, I THINK THIS
IS WHAT THOSE GIRLS DO..."
YOU COULD'VE BEEN, LIKE,
"EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL."
THAT'S YOU.
YOU HAVE TO BRING WHO YOU ARE
AND MARRY IT TO THE PRODUCT.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR
COOKIE-CUTTER GIRLS.
IF THAT'S THE CASE,
NONE OF YOU GUYS WOULD BE HERE.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST--BRITTANY.
>> (imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK...
(voice breaks) IN MY LOOK.
(blows raspberry)
(normal voice) TAKE 20.
(imitating Australian accent)
NEW VolumeExact MASCARA,
WITH ITS REVOLUTIONARY BRUSH...
SHOOT.
G'DAY, MATE!
HE THINKS I'M THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL SHEILA
HE'S SEEN IN THE BUSH.
NOW THAT'S EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
>> LOOKING AT YOU
IN THE COMMERCIAL,
IT LOOKED LIKE YOU
WERE NEAR TEARS.
WHY?
>> (crying) I JUST HAD
A REALLY HARD TIME WITH IT
BECAUSE OF MY SHORT-TERM MEMORY.
I GOT HIT BY A CAR WHEN I WAS 17
WHEN I WAS CROSSING THE STREET,
AND I CRACKED MY HEAD OPEN
ON THE CURB.
I HAD EIGHT STAPLES IN MY HEAD,
AND IT AFFECTED
MY SHORT-TERM MEMORY.
>> FASHION HAS NO SYMPATHY
OR EMPATHY.
>> WE HAVE HEARTS.
WE'VE KNOWN YOU
FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS AND WEEKS,
SO WE'RE SOFTENED TO YOU
AND SEE YOU AS A HUMAN BEING,
BUT... THE WORLD OF FASHION
AND ADVERTISING...
>> I KNOW.
I KNOW THAT I REALLY, REALLY
NEED TO WORK ON IT.
>> YES, YOU NEED TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WORKS FOR YOU.
>> THERE WERE SOME LOVELY
MOMENTS WITH YOUR ACCENT.
THERE WERE A FEW LITTLE HINTS...
>> THERE WERE.
>> YEAH.
>> OF A BEAUTIFUL AUSTRALIAN
ACCENT, SO...
>> AND I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
THE SILENT PART OF YOUR FILMING
WAS BEAUTIFUL.
YOU--YOU--YOU DIDN'T OVERDO IT
LIKE SOME OF THE OTHERS HAVE.
I THOUGHT YOU LOOKED GORGEOUS.
>> THANK YOU.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE
JUDGES TO DELIBERATE
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU...
>> (whispers) IS GOING UNDER.
>> WILL BE THE FIRST--
>> YEAH, THEY'RE NOT
GOING UNDER,
GOING BACK OVER...FIRST GIRL
THAT WILL BE SENT HOME.
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO JUDGE...
(imitates Australian accent)
THE COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
ARE YOU READY?
>> (groans)
>> (normal voice) DIONNE.
>> I WAS JUST UNIMPRESSED
BY THE WHOLE PERFORMANCE
BY DIONNE.
IT--IT MADE NO IMPACT ON ME
WHATSOEVER.
>> I-I FORGOT WHAT
SHE WAS TELLING US ABOUT.
IT DIDN'T MAKE SENSE.
>> I THINK DIONNE IS THAT GIRL
THAT NEEDS TO DO IT AND DO IT
AND DO IT AGAIN,
AND THEN ONCE SHE'S DONE IT
TEN TIMES,
SHE'S GONNA BE FANTASTIC.
RENEE.
>> SHE WAS ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
I--AGAIN, I LOVE
HER SPEAKING VOICE.
>> SHE WAS REALLY CONSISTENT
WITH THE ENERGY THROUGHOUT.
>> JAEL.
>> YOU KNOW, IF JAEL TURNED UP
FOR ANY MAJOR FASHION MAGAZINE
AND MET THE EDITOR,
I DON'T THINK SHE'D GET
THROUGH THE DOOR.
>> WHEN THE GIRLS
ROLLED OFF THE PLANE,
SHE WAS IMMEDIATELY
THE MOST ENDEARING.
YOU WANT SOMEONE WHO LOVES
WHAT THEY'RE DOING, WHO'S
EXCITED EVERY SINGLE DAY,
AND SHE'S THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, I'VE GOTTA TELL
YOU, I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
SHE'S REALLY BORING.
SHE DOES NOTHING FOR ME.
>> BRITTANY.
>> SHE WAS VERY, VERY UPSET,
AND IT SHOWED ON THE COMMERCIAL.
AND NERVES LIKE THAT,
YOU'VE GOT TO LEARN TO CONQUER.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
SHORT-TERM MEMORY?
>> FOR ME, I THINK WITH
EVERY JOB THAT YOU DO,
YOU DEVELOP A STRATEGY...
>> MM-HMM.
>> FOR HOW YOU'RE GONNA DEAL
WITH WHATEVER FLAWS OR
DEFECTS THAT YOU HAVE.
>> BUT DON'T YOU GUYS THINK--
I MEAN, SHE WAS IN
A CAR ACCIDENT,
AND HER HEAD WAS CRACKED OPEN.
>> SO YOU CAN EXCUSE HER
NOT ON SELLING THE LINES.
I UNDERSTAND THE NOT--
BUT THAT--BUT THE--
WHEN SHE CAN'T TAKE
THE CRITICISM AND THE UPSET,
IT'S JUST NOT A--YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT ATTRACTIVE.
>> NATASHA.
>> I THOUGHT SHE WAS GREAT
CONSIDERING THAT ENGLISH
IS HER SECOND LANGUAGE...
>> RIGHT.
>> AND AUSSIE IS HER THIRD.
WELL, SECOND AND A HALF.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
SHE IS NOT GOOD AT ENGLISH,
BUT SHE ROCKED THAT COMMERCIAL.
I FELT LIKE I WAS LOOKING
AT A REAL COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
JASLENE.
>> ME NOT KNOWING HER
AND NOT KNOWING ALL
OF THAT DRAG ACTIVITY...
>> (laughs)
>> IT WAS...
YEAH, IT WAS OVERWHELMING.
>> THE FACT THAT SHE'S
IN THIS ROOM AND SHE SAW IT,
I THINK SHE'LL KNOW
HOW TO PULL BACK.
AND AS I'VE SAID EVERY WEEK,
IT'S SO MUCH EASIER
TO PULL A GIRL BACK.
SHE'S GOT ALL THIS
DA-DA-DA-DA-DA-DA-DA.
JUST PULL IT BACK,
AND I THINK SHE CAN GET IT.
WE'VE REACHED THE DECISION...
FIRST GIRL GOING BACK
TO AMERICA.
♪♪♪
>> SIX GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE FIVE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE TAKEN
WHAT WE CALL SCREEN CAPTURES
FROM YOUR COMMERCIAL
AND CREATED A PHOTO.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL STILL BE IN
THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
>> NATASHA.
THESE GIRLS HAVE SOMEONE
TO BE SCARED OF.
YOU IMPRESSED THE JUDGES,
AND THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M CALLING TODAY
IS THE WINNER OF THE CHALLENGE.
THE JUDGES WATCHED THE
CORRESPONDENT PIECES,
AND, NATASHA, WE DECIDED
YOURS IS BEST.
I WILL BE SEEING YOU
ON MY TALK SHOW...
>> OH!
>> AS A CORRESPONDENT.
>> I CANNOT BELIEVE IT!
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
RENEE.
(exaggerated Australian accent)
HEY THERE!
>> (laughs)
>> I CALLED TO TELL YOU
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
(normal voice) IT'S A
NATURAL THING FOR YOU.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PERFORM
SO MUCH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME I'M
GOING TO CALL...
JASLENE.
IN TERMS OF YOUR COMMERCIAL,
YOU DID AN OKAY JOB,
BUT JUST RELAX.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME I'M
GOING TO CALL...
DIONNE.
YOU LOOKED ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL
IN THIS COMMERCIAL.
BUT WE WANNA SEE THE REAL YOU
WHEN YOU DELIVER A COMMERCIAL.
YOU GOT THE GOODS.
YOUR FACE IS SO SPARKLY
RIGHT NOW.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> WILL BRITTANY AND JAEL
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL
THAT IS STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
BRITTANY, YOU TAKE
SOME OF THE STRONGEST PICTURES.
BUT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS
IN THIS COMPETITION
IS DELIVERING
A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
SO WHEN THE JUDGES SEE A MODEL
THAT TAKES BEAUTIFUL PICTURES
BUT THEN DELIVERS
A COMMERCIAL LIKE THAT,
WE GET SCARED.
AND THE JUDGES
TRIED TO BE COMPASSIONATE
WHEN IT CAME TO THE PROBLEM
WITH YOUR SHORT-TERM MEMORY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
THEY CAN'T FAVOR YOU
BECAUSE OF THAT.
AND, JAEL--BEAUTIFUL PICTURES
THROUGHOUT THIS COMPETITION,
BUT HOW YOU PRESENT YOURSELF ON
FILM IS GHASTLY.
FOR A GIRL TO HAVE
SO MUCH PERSONALITY
AND SO MUCH SPUNK
AND SO MUCH FIRE--
TO SEE HER FALL SO FLAT,
IT MAKES THE JUDGES
NERVOUS, TOO.
SO THAT'S WHY BOTH OF YOU
STAND SIDE-BY-SIDE RIGHT NOW.
>> BRITTANY.
♪♪♪
>> (mouths words)
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU
IN YOUR ACCIDENT, BRITTANY,
IS AWFUL.
BUT YOU'RE HERE,
AND YOU'RE STRONG
AND YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL
ON THE INSIDE AND THE OUTSIDE.
SO YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
EVERY SINGLE TRICK IN THE BOOK
THAT YOU CAN DO
TO MEMORIZE LINES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> BYE, JAEL.
>> OH.
TYRA, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> HONESTLY, LIKE,
THIS EXPERIENCE HAS
CHANGED MY LIFE TREMENDOUSLY.
AND IT'S OKAY.
I LOVE ALL OF YOU TO DEATH.
>> YOU HAVE A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
YOU JUST GOTTA GET THIS
TOGETHER.
>> (laughs)
>> YOU GET THAT TOGETHER,
YOU ARE...
(snaps fingers)
>> OH.
OH, COME ON!
(voice breaks) I LOVE YOU
GUYS SO MUCH.
IT'S OKAY.
>> I'VE BEEN THROUGH
SO MUCH HERE, AND IT'S BEEN
SUCH A LEARNING EXPERIENCE,
AND I'M SO THANKFUL
TO HAVE HAD IT.
I AM SO PROUD
THAT I'VE GOTTEN THIS FAR.
I AM GOING TO MISS
EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF THE 13 GIRLS
THAT FIRST STARTED OFF
IN THIS HOUSE,
EQUALLY IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
I'VE CREATED BONDS
WITH EACH AND EVERY ONE OF THEM,
AND I MAY BE THE ONLY PERSON
WHO'S BEEN HERE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO DO SO.
♪♪♪
>> COMING UP ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL,"
WHEN IT'S TIME TO IMPRESS
THE DESIGNERS DOWN UNDER...
>> WHAT'S YOUR NAME AGAIN?
>> NENE.
>> I'M WAYWAY.
♪♪♪
>> BRITTANY LEAVES HER
MANNERS BEHIND.
>> IT'S NOT OKAY!
>> IT IS OKAY.
>> IT SUCKS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT MY... FAULT!
IT'S HIS, 'CAUSE I ASKED HIM
TO MEET ME OVER THERE.